the name of this place is bani shanta
it means a message of calm
but on this narrow strip of land there
is little peace
these huts form one of the country's
oldest brothels
here women call themselves girls
many have been trafficked some because
of the impact of climate change
when pervin was 15 her family's coastal
home and farm were destroyed through
rising sea levels
the loss made the family desperate which
made pervin a target
for sex traffickers
and
has never told her family she was
trafficked she still
sends money home
around a hundred women work in bani
shanta
and although brothels are legal in
bangladesh they are still taboo
sex workers and their children are
hugely stigmatized
here at least there is a sense of
community
but climate change is eroding that too
their land is disappearing chipped away
by rising sea levels
and hit by a vicious cyclone last year
we talk about the front line of climate
change and you think about villages
being washed away and that is happening
here but this is also a story about
a community and women who've become
double victims really they've come here
because of climate change happening
where they've come from
but now because of this they've become
victims again
and as this river rises they are running
out of options
sugar shopper a fellow man
the chief madam here tells us they can't
move further back
they're stuck between a river that
floods them to the front and behind
a village that doesn't want them and
where they couldn't work
because if there is any way out money is
it
rina was sold into sex work when she was
10.
she now has an eight-month-old baby son
called chandon
she hopes one day they can leave but
knows there is little dignity
for those that stay
foreign
climate change affects us all but it
also
exposes vulnerabilities and affects some
so much more than others katarina
vitotsi sky news in banishanta
bangladesh